[Music]
on this monday night the omicron variant
detected in canada new cases are
confirmed in multiple provinces there's
no reason to panic the many unknowns
about this new variant how some
countries are responding and how it
could affect holiday travel
rising waters and rising fears as
another atmospheric river heads for d.c
plus sponge cities one way communities
could absorb water instead of repelling
it ottawa's new bill to ban conversion
therapy you just watch people basically
destroy themselves one survivor's trauma
and why barbados is relinquishing the
royals and becoming a republic
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are tracking developments related to
the omicron variant of the coronavirus
which has now been detected in multiple
countries including canada scientists
including in south africa where it was
first detected are working to get
reliable data from patients who are
infected but it could be two or three
weeks to get answers omicron has a high
number of mutations including to the
spike protein the virus uses to invade
host cells and among the key questions
is it much more transmissible than other
variants does it cause more severe
illness and how capable is it of evading
vaccines
early evidence suggests it can spread
rapidly but there remains so much
uncertainty some countries are not
waiting they've imposed tight
restrictions we'll get to that in a
moment but we begin with abigail beeman
and canada's response to this new
variant
first two confirmed cases in ottawa both
individuals are in isolation
another two confirmed in the capitol
late monday plus one in quebec we are
still making some inquiries to see
exactly when but that case came from
nigeria nigeria is not one of the seven
african countries canada slapped with
heightened travel restrictions
ottawa public health is working
diligently on conducting case and
contact management there's a concerning
hitch ottawa public health put out a
rare news release trying to find a man
who drove a white car in a private ride
share he picked up a passenger from the
montreal airport wednesday night and
drove that person to the ottawa suburb
of bar haven public health says the
driver was likely exposed to covet and
they want him to isolate but citing
privacy they won't say whether that case
was one of the omicron cases detected in
two ottawa residents who first landed in
montreal from nigeria there are also two
suspected cases in hamilton after travel
to south africa
we have been informed that 115 travelers
from countries affected by the new
variant have been called to do a new pcr
test and isolate themselves ontario says
the federal public health agency told
them there are
375 people in that province who fit the
bill traveling from the seven restricted
countries in the last two weeks bc says
just over 200 there and up to a thousand
across the country the federal agency
wouldn't confirm any numbers to global
news by deadline the one thing i want to
make sure is that we don't panic there
are there are reasons for why we are
concerned
but we are not panicked don't panic
since much about omicron is still not
known including its resistance to
vaccines
we might see this chip away or erode at
some of that protection i would be
shocked if our vaccines that we're using
are you know deemed to be quote unquote
useless as for what can be done ontario
and quebec are pushing for more testing
measures at the border quebec says all
provinces lobbied the feds for that this
weekend the federal health minister
would only say he'll have more to say
soon donna abigail beeman in ottawa
thanks the u.s president says he does
not expect the u.s to impose new travel
restrictions to try to limit the spread
of the omicron variant many other
countries though are moving quickly at
least 14 countries are now reporting
cases in addition to canada cases have
been confirmed in south africa botswana
australia germany the netherlands the uk
italy belgium portugal and the czech
republic
omicron's very emergence is another
reminder that although many of us might
think we're done with covet 19.
it's not done with us
the who's director general says the
global risk is very high and he is
urging countries to accelerate
vaccination of high priority groups mike
armstrong is tracking developments from
washington
just as the world was loosening travel
restrictions they're back in japan entry
rules were softened just weeks ago and
the country is now banning as of
wednesday the arrival of all foreign
nationals
the japanese prime minister admits his
country's reaction is stronger than most
others
now most but not all
israel is temporarily banning all
arrivals while morocco is suspending all
incoming flights for two weeks
the number of confirmed cases around the
globe is still small but it's growing
and in a lot of places one of the latest
added to the omicron list spain a 51
year old who returned from south africa
sunday
the new variant has ripped through a
soccer team in portugal 13 cases so far
one player had recently traveled home to
south africa to play for the national
team
several countries are now restricting
travel from south africa as well as
other countries in that region experts
say it's not to stop the spread of
omicron but to at least slow it down
with new variants he who hesitates is
lost if you if you wait for certainty or
for more information it then becomes too
late to do anything very effective
president biden is calling the omacron
virus cause for concern but not a cause
for panic sooner or later we're going to
see cases of this new variant here in
the united states now so far omicron
appears to be more contagious than other
variants but not necessarily more deadly
it'll take several weeks for scientists
to determine the threat
one part of that is lab tests the other
is statistical analysis of how patients
with omicron react it can take up to two
to three weeks to see if they go into a
hospital or even worse if they die now
countries that haven't been affected are
watching the ones that have whereas most
of the travel restrictions being
announced concerned countries in
southern africa
others are being added to the list
switzerland announced monday it's
bringing back its quarantine program for
people arriving from
among others
canada
donna all right mike armstrong in
washington thanks
children in bc aged five to 11 are the
latest in canada to roll up their
sleeves for the covet 19 shot about 350
000 children are eligible for a dose of
the pfizer biantec vaccine more than 92
thousand children are registered and
invitations to book appointments are
rolling out in order of registration
bc's top doctor says more than 3 million
children have received the vaccine in
the united states already with no major
safety issues
british columbia has extended the state
of emergency caused by extreme weather
until mid-december some highways remain
closed gas rationing is still in effect
non-essential travel is not advised and
fresh evacuation orders are in place as
another atmospheric river is forecast
heather yorick's west reports on how the
city of abbotsford is bracing for what's
to come
south of the canada u.s border the city
of sumas is under water after heavy
rains and snow melt caused the nooksack
river to flood its banks it is very hard
very hard
i am thinking about the people who have
lost everything what they can do how can
they survive
in the abbotsford neighborhood of
huntington village residents vijay and
shashi gautam spent the weekend watching
the water levels closely as water
crossed the border but a sandbag dike
built over the weekend by residents and
the canadian military is so far keeping
their homes safe and dry though the same
can't be said for this business just
beyond the berm i was shocked this
morning when we woke up that
that we survived it i thought we had we
had dodged a bullet but it
and then the water started rising
envirocorp recycling had just gotten
back to work after last week's flooding
now water has shut it down a second time
still there is a general sense of relief
in this community at least for the time
being there's no more coming over right
now it's kind of subsided a little bit
but we are preparing for the next
weather storm that we're all worrying
about coming tomorrow
it's why more preparations are underway
dozens of volunteers spent monday
filling hundreds of sandbags as the city
prepares for the arrival of yet another
atmospheric river
today's the day we have nice weather
let's get you sandbagged so that we're
more prepared rather than the panic that
sets in when it's pouring rain and we've
got hundreds of volunteers out here
getting soaked trying to do it highway
one east of abbotsford was closed sunday
night after water from the sumas river
began to overflow it's why the military
and others work to construct this tiger
dam along the highway and for now the
roadway remains closed it went through
the night
the effort was incredible to protect
highway one through the fraser valley
compared to the devastation of last
week's floods the city appears to have
come through the weekend storm
relatively well but with much more rain
around the corner anxiety levels remain
high very anxious
it's it's it's not easy living in oxford
right now
heather urex west global news abbotsford
pc
environment canada is warning the next
weather system expected tonight will
deliver what it calls a relatively
strong punch 50 to 100 millimeters of
rain is forecast nearly all of
southwestern b.c is under a flood watch
now and the region in red on this map is
under a flood warning because rivers are
close to bursting their banks in some
places that means evacuation orders are
back in effect robin gill reports
it just doesn't end for the people of
merit bc once again running away from
water people just want to get back home
and
start dealing with their lives
cleaning up
residents were slowly returning in
phases after a flood overwhelmed the
city of 7 000 people two weeks ago but
the rain keeps coming and another
evacuation order was put in place the
levels that we saw last night would
historically have been considered a high
water mark
but as it was they were actually less
than half of what came through two weeks
ago so there's still a lot of water
which is coming through merit at this
point and we're just managing it as best
we can city crews have been able to
protect critical infrastructure repair
dikes and reinforce banks along the cold
water river all along the wet west coast
there are flood warnings and watches
that's because of all the rivers that
are affected take heart hit merit caught
within the nicola and coldwater rivers
the latter of which is the cause for
concern and in princeton bc a town that
describes itself as where rivers meet
the tulamine and simulcamine are making
life difficult for the people there
people are getting worn out
there's no other way to say it i mean
you you go online in the morning and you
see people
just you know
just just hanging on
and
at some point you know we need a break
but no one in this water weary part of
british columbia is getting a break it's
not just a rain event it's not just the
snow melting event it's also a
successive storm event these are anxious
times thank god the water didn't come
out to my house so
it was nice it's nice to go home and
check it the record-breaking rain has
saturated this soil and made life so
hard for so many here with more rain
coming the raging rivers could put more
properties and more lives in limbo robin
gill global news vancouver
canada moves another step closer to
outlawing conversion therapy coming up
what one man endured undergoing the
discredited practice
the federal government has introduced
new legislation to ban what's known as
conversion therapy it's the discredited
practice of attempting to change an
individual's sexual orientation to
heterosexual or their gender identity to
cisgender if passed the bill would
outlaw conversion therapy altogether
whether it involves a minor or an adult
and anyone who tries to practice or
promote it could face charges
people who have gone through the agony
of it hope it will spare others from the
same experience mike lookature reports
i constantly have that doubt of am i
actually evil or sick or not it will
always be there that that way of that
track of thinking the scars of
conversion therapy have only started to
heal for adam frey the 36 year old spent
nearly a decade going through the
controversial and scientifically
unfounded practice of trying to change
his sexual orientation all at the urging
of his family young earth creationists
belief in the demonic that i was
demonized his family even performed an
exorcism on him frey says leaving
conversion therapy meant having the
strength to be seen as evil or sick by
those closest to him
but it came with a cost it's definitely
marked me i've been estranged from my
family for 10 years
i have nine nieces and nephews that i
haven't seen
frey does have a sense of hope today
with the reintroduction of the bill
banning conversion therapy in children
and adults outright an earlier version
only made it a criminal offense to force
adults to undergo the practice there's
no way to consent to something that is
inherently barbaric inherently abusive
in the last parliament the bill faced
some opposition from half the
conservative caucus and then was held up
in the senate they will say this bill
harms religious freedoms
it does not
they will say this bill harms freedom of
expression
it does not the liberals hope those
arguments get the bill passed as quickly
as possible
michael couture global news ottawa
two years after convicted pedophile
jeffrey epstein died in jail while
awaiting trial for sex trafficking his
longtime companion is standing trial a
jury will determine whether gelain
maxwell was epstein's accomplice in
opening statements prosecutors described
maxwell as a predator saying she and
epstein were partners in crime the
59-year-old is charged with six counts
related to sex trafficking she is
accused of recruiting and grooming
underage girls for epstein to sexually
abuse the trial is expected to last over
a month and if convicted maxwell faces
up to 80 years in prison
twitter ceo jack dorsey has announced he
is leaving the social media platform he
helped create the 45 year co-founded
twitter in 2006 he announced his
departure in a tweet saying there aren't
many companies that get to this level
and there aren't many founders that
choose their company over their own ego
twitter shares soared with the news this
morning dorsey is also ceo of the
payment firm square and some investors
questioned whether he could be effective
leading both companies dorsey will be
replaced by twitter's chief technical
officer parag agrawal
next the spongy solution to make cities
more resilient to floods
[Music]
after every extreme weather event it
becomes clear we need to find ways to be
more resilient most of our cities and
our infrastructure are not designed to
handle record amounts of rainfall that
because of climate change is becoming
more common there's a new idea taking
root that harnesses the power of nature
and absorbs water like a sponge mike
drollet explains how it works
there's no one doing the damage in
british columbia weeks into an
unrelenting flood the hope is that it
doesn't get any worse
eventually the lost roads and houses
will be rebuilt but to avoid a repeat
urban planners say we need a dramatic
change
in the way we think
our concrete-laden cities have long been
developed on the premise that we can
control flooding with storm drains but
when it rains too much those drains get
overwhelmed to solve that problem
engineers have turned to nature
green space they've discovered acts like
a sponge soaking up in releasing water
slowly cities are
areas that a lot of the natural surfaces
have been covered with concrete or other
paved surfaces and what that in effect
does is it doesn't allow
water
including rain water to go where it
naturally would which is
below the ground china didn't develop
the idea of the sponge city but they've
embraced it the city of chongqing for
one recently converted 99 hectares into
a wetland park which now acts like a
giant sponge but that's china where
change happens fast
well not as dramatic a transformation
toronto is redeveloping its portlands
with an eye towards increased future
flooding this desolate looking plot of
land will have an over abundance of
green space for aesthetics yes but
mostly necessity
toronto used to have a large system of
streams which naturally controlled
flooding but they've all been vanished
there's only so much city planners can
do when the neighborhoods we live in are
dominated by hard surfaces kitchener
ontario saw that problem and got
creative incentivizing residents to
lower their storm water tax by creating
more green space on their properties
there can be debate about the cause of
climate change but i don't think there's
a lot of debate about the fact that it
is occurring so
in order to try to mitigate
any negative impacts from
from those changes
we are implementing strategies today in
order to protect ourselves in the future
you could say they're trying to stay dry
by soaking up new ideas microlight
global news toronto
next why barbados is severing ties with
the queen
[Music]
sweden's political roller coaster took
another big turn today the country
reelected its prime minister who
resigned last week just hours after
taking the post magdalena anderson and
her social democrats won by a narrow
margin in a new vote today she will
attempt to lead until the election next
september anderson who was previously
finance minister had stepped down after
her two-party coalition collapsed over
her proposed budget
the caribbean nation of barbados is
starting a new chapter in its history
it's out with the queen and in with a
president the first commonwealth country
in nearly three decades to declare
itself a republic the split is amicable
though prince charles flew to barbados
to watch it all happen redmond shannon
explains why barbados is cutting ties
with the british monarchy
for barbados republicans this moment of
celebration is generations in the making
that colonial cloak
a wicked british joke
no longer cover us
sunset on the empire the first british
ship landed in barbados in 1625
hundreds of thousands of africans were
sent into slavery on the island's
plantations until emancipation in the
1800s it wasn't until the 1960s that
barbados became independent prime
minister mia motley taking the next step
in 2021 welcoming prince charles to the
event the man who would have been the
country's next head of state her job is
to bring barbados forward to the 21st
century
and to get our grip away from the slave
master grip but there is some unease
about how the formal process was pushed
through parliament without ever
consulting the public via referendum i
guess that the public they really had
much say on that for the government to
do this here to the people of barbados
it's very wrong and i see it as illegal
there are 15 other commonwealth realms
including canada 22 years ago australian
voters rejected a republic partly
because the proposal involved a
president elected by lawmakers rather
than voters barbados is adopting that
system with outgoing governor general
sandra mason becoming president so it's
possible that once barbados becomes a
republic we may see renewed calls for
that in jamaica as well royal historian
carolyn harris says any path to a
canadian republic is far more complex
even if polls suggest most canadians
think the monarchy is out of date and
it's very difficult for all ten
provinces to be on the same page at the
same time
also treaties with indigenous peoples or
with the crown as the crown fades from
prominence in barbados
there are at least some legacies of
empire that remain redmond shannon
global news london
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is front knack provincial park
north of kingston ontario we'd love to
see your canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you